вітаємо це програма У фокусі Європа я
Лара бабалола Ласкаво просимо на шоу
Балкани це порахував бочка яка роками
тримає єсу напрузі Лише кілька тижнів
тому були побоювання що може спалахнути
збройний конфлікт між Косово і сербією у
грудні сербській протестувальники
перекрили дороги на півночі Косово вони
вимагали зокрема звільнити серба
затриманого за напад на косовську
поліцію напруженість із зросла і Сербія
привела свою армію у стан підвищеної
бойової готовності
європейські Союз нещодавно опублікував
Мирний плани для нормалізації ситуації в
Косово
обидві сторони схвалили плани які
включає посилення прав сербської меншини
в Косово на самоврядування групи яка
відмовляється визнати Косово як
незалежно країну
понад 20 років міжнародні миротворчі
сили кейфор виступають посередниками між
двома етнічними групами для підтримання
стабільності в Косово врівноважені
ситуації в розколотій країні
у минулому вони були кращі озброєні але
для солдатів міжнародних миротворчих сил
кейфор пістолети зараз мають радше
символічне значення наразі ситуація на
півночі Косово спокійна У маленькому
містечку липосович є можливість
поспілкуватись із місцевими жителями під
час однієї з наших зупинок ресторанів ми
дізналися що сталося відключення
електроенергії і ми просто спробували
з'ясувати наскільки далеко поширилися
відключення електроенергії І як це
впливає на місцеве населення зараз
у місцевій лікарні лікар підтверджує що
сталося відключення але каже що у них є
аварійні генератори
відключення електроенергії тут може мати
значення для військових
солдати збирають інформацію де тільки
можуть перед обов'язковою чашкою кави
Косово нещодавно відсвяткувало 15 років
Незалежності але в лепосові чи вивішені
лише сербські прапори на стіні
видніються зухвалі слова це Сербія Не
бійтеся ми тут щоб захистити вас
Ми намагаємося тримати нейтральну
позицію Ми не хочемо виглядати занадто
агресивними чи ще якимось тому що
зрештою Ми також люди Ми також розуміємо
проблеми та занепокоєння які в них є
ми слідуємо за миротворцями на північ до
кордону де вони регулярно патрулюють І
на те є вагомі причини
[оплески]
кілька тижнів тому на кордоні стався
спалах коли радикально налаштовані Серби
зіткнулися з косовськими албанцями
напруга зросла до максимуму за довгий
час не в останню чергу через появу
невідомої групи людей у масках
[музика]
це росіяни каже серп на цьому відео
знятому на мобільний телефон існують
припущення що найманці і сумнозвісної
групи Вагнера були задіяні як агітатори
за російським наказом
keyfor спостерігали за тим що
відбувається не втручаючись солдати
втручаються лише тоді коли косовські та
європейські поліцейські сили не можуть
взяти ситуацію під контроль
мій підрозділ зокрема відповідав за
верхівку пагорба посаду нас за цю
місцевість в цілому
ми стежили за тим щоб туди не приїжджав
в сторонній транспорт і щоб інші
підрозділи нашої роти були напоготові
щоб у разі потреби надати підтримку
косовській поліції
ніде поділ Косово не проявляється так
явно як у місті метровиця де на півдні
проживають переважно косовський албанці
А на півночі косовські серби
поліція ЄС охороняє міст який з'єднує Ці
дві частини на албанській стороні люди
говорять про свій страх і недовіру
Ми не маємо жодного відношення до людей
з того боку
Я боюся говорити тому що я часто туди
ходжу і вони можуть мені щось зробити
на півночі всюди висять сербські прапори
єдина людина яка захотіла з нами
поговорити підліток
як зробити так щоб було краще я не знаю
Можливо якщо Косово буде повністю
належати Сербії
Ми не ходимо на той бік у нас там немає
друзів тому що ми залишаємось Отут на
півночі в Сербії
Косово і Сербія погодилася на пропозицію
спрямовано на стабілізацію відносин І
хоча обидві сторони ще не підписали
угоду це перший проблиск Надії за довгий
час
імені оптимізму то це тиск західних
країн на Сербію
оточена Європейським Союзом і НАТО
[музика]
на зворотному шляху до бази солдати
кейфор зустрічають групу сербів які
протестують проти експропріації майна
косовської держави
якби це було ваших силах і ви або ваша
начальство могли поговорити з лідерами
та відповідальними особами в Пристані це
б нам дуже допомогло
ось дивіться Найбільше що можна зробити
передати цю інформацію але що я можу
зробити для вас хлопці Адже спочатку ми
не думали що нам раді на протесті
розумієте що я маю на увазі але ми
можемо зупинитися походити і показати що
ми тут розумієте що я маю на увазі що
продемонструвати єдність Ну щось таке це
круто Хочеш перекласти
Серби стверджують що в лісі ховаються
снайпери косовської поліції І дійсно є
кілька патрульних машин які здалеку
стежить за Протестом нам не дозволяють
знімати
недовіра глибоко проникає у Косово з
обох сторін і мало що вказує на те що це
зміниться найближчим часом
скарби океану які існу
ють ці природ
ні з лише дайверів та екологів але і
ювелірів червоний корали Середземного
моря найбажаніший і він зустрічається у
великій кількості в італійському торе
Дель греко але ці організми знаходяться
під загрозою не лише через зміни клімату
але й через браконьєрство контрабандисти
видобувають дорогоцінні червоні корали
щоб отримати свою частку від
багатомільйонної індустрії Міко катальдо
продавець який знає до яких хитрощів
даються контрабандисти щоб уникнути
відповідальності
Неаполь південь Італії протягом століття
цей регіон славився коралами
під цінню везувію знаходиться торе Дель
греко неофіційна столиця світової
торгівлі коралами
місцеві бізнес-лідери налаштовані
оптимістично прикраси з червоного коралу
знову користуються попитом міжнародні
модні та ювелірні бренди стікаються до
торе Дель греко місцеве підприємлиця
Марія де сімоне вважає що цьому успіху
сприяє серйозна прихильність до
збереження природи вона каже що її
бізнес суворо дотримується правил
захисту довкілля вона знає про
нелегальну торгівлю коралами але каже що
це зовсім інший світ
у вас є ім'я У вас є історія вам є що
захищати і ви не можете дозволити собі
робити це є багато фабрик у тому числі і
маленьких які мають хороше ім'я хорошу
репутацію і я впевнена що вони не мають
нічого спільного і з цими людьми
згодом ми знаходимо торговці який
погодився обговорити Темний бік торгівлі
коралами Міко катальдо каже що атмосфера
нагадує золоту лихоманку Він каже що
хоча Влада пильно стежить за цією
проблемою контрабандисти продовжують
знаходити нові шляхи
я скажу Щось дуже-дуже сміливе вони
везуть товар курали до Іспанії
[музика]
з Іспанії вони їдуть до Франції та
Італії
вони знаходять інші способи
Ми вирушаємо на інший берег Середземного
моря ми в табарці на північному
узбережжі Середземного моря в Тунісі
століттями все тут оберталося навколо
дорогоцінних коралів Але на відміну від
деталі бізнес тут іде неспішно місцеві
жителі кажуть нам що 90% магазинів
закрились тому що коралів більше немає
у якийсь момент ймовірно коралів взагалі
не залишиться вони вимруть дефіцит вже
робить їх недоступним для тутешніх людей
у них немає грошей
хто може дозволити собі високоякісні
коралові прикраси може художники чи
бізнесмени
салах джауї роками працював кораловим
дайвером він запевняє що завжди
дотримувався правил але тепер він став
за старим для цієї роботи і дозволяє
іншим дайверам користуватися своїм
човном
зараз відбувається дуже багато
незаконного вилову
і це створює величезні проблеми для нас
оскільки це руйнує наші запаси коралів і
семецьке дно
якщо на скелі росте 10 кг коралів то
незаконні методи вилову знищать все
середовище існування навколо неї
9 кілограмів коралів буде втрачено і
лише один кілограм добуток
Він каже що корали контрабандою
переправляє через Туніс і розсилають по
всьому світу попит на них особливо
високий у Південній Європі та Азії Він
каже що владі важко перевірити
походження коралів
нещодавно спіймали італійця на човні
який нелегально перевозив корали до
Італії
Усі знають що тут процвітає контрабандою
Берегова охорона регулярно проводить
обшуки катерів У маленькому Порту табаки
три роки тому вони викрили мережу
контрабандистів з Алжиру Тунісу та
Іспанії з обігом торгівлі коралами у
мільйони євро
Вони зазвичай зберігають товар у місті
бізерта або в столиці Тунісі
потім намагаються експортувати
маршрут до Італії звідти курали часто
везуть аж до Індії
У багатьох країнах Азії вважається що ці
підводні мешканці мають корисні для
здоров'я властивості і навіть
надприродну силу злочинні мережі йдуть
на все щоб заробити на дорогоцінних
коралах які часто живуть на глибині
сотень метрів під поверхнею ювелірний
майстер Мурат арфауї переконаний що всі
проблеми які загрожують коралам
пов'язані з однією причиною людиною та
її жадібністю
інших видів наші корали гинуть тому що
ми більше не даємо їм часу на ріст і
розвиток ми просто більше не цінуємо
скарби наших океанів
у торе Дель греко проблеми
північно-африканських торговців здаються
далекими проте багато хто усвідомлює
якщо не вжити заходів для боротьби з
нелегальною торгівлею то запаси коралів
можуть вичерпатися назавжди
протягом століть торф використовувався в
ірландських домівках як паливо та
джерело тепла в країні не вистачає інших
природних ресурсів таких як вугілля
нафта і газ торф або торф'яник не лише
широкопоширений в Ірландії А ще й
дешевий багато людей у сільській
місцевості створюють власні запаси для
опалення та приготування їжі Ноель
конрол один із них він стурбований
планом уряду заборонити викопування
торфу не займені торфовища зберігають
величезну кількість СО2 і можуть
зменшити викиди парникових газів але для
мешканців ірландської сільської
місцевості така кліматично чиста
альтернатива для обігріву та
забезпечення паливом своїх будинків не
привабливий варіант
і його сестра філіс прайс мають
справжній скарб у своєму саду їхнє
володіння в ірландському мітленді
охоплюють було тисну місцевість і щороку
вони збирають торф або торф'яник для
опалення свого будинку
хороша частина яку можна спалювати
знаходиться на цьому рівні І це
коричневий торф
такої глибини аж до самого кінця
достатньо щоб обігрівати один будинок
протягом року
Ця сім'я збирає торф уже поколіннями
брати і сестри їхні діти всі вони
опалюють торфом це частина культури Але
можливо ненадовго спалювання торфу дуже
шкодить клімату ірландський уряд хочу
покласти цьому край Ну я не думаю що ми
завдаємо такої великої шкоди Подивіться
хоча б на всі ці літаки вгорі і ми
ніколи не отримаємо нічого дешевшого
затор у нас немає нафти у нас є тільки
торф'яник запас торфу рятує їх від
стрімкого зростання рахунків за
електроенергію раз на рік вони за
допомогою техніки збирають і нарізають
торф потім його відкладають сушитися і
все
торфу тут на 250 євро і його вистачить
більше ніж на рік
в Ірландії близько 100 тисяч людей досі
збирають торф із місцевих боліт щоб
обігрівати свої будинки багато хто
бореться за те щоб залишити все як є
Минулого року уряд намагався запровадити
частково заборону на видобуток торфу
Це викликало гнів у сільській місцевості
зокрема тут у кларі
майже у 90% будинків тут спалюють торф
місцеві політики та лобісти такі як ще
йому з боленд робили все можливе щоб
зняти ці обмеження кажучи що вони були
запроваджені занадто швидко
коли ви запроваджуєте закон не маючи
підтримки для його реалізації ви
створюєте величезні проблеми і біль
і для людей практичної фізично Неможливо
здійснити ці зміни
це одна сторона історії але
тристамбувать каже що є й інша і час має
вирішальне значення торфово що можуть
творити чудеса у боротьбі зі змінними
клімату та викидами CO2 Він доклав
багато зусиль для відновлення цього
болота Вони беруть вуглець з повітря і
замикають його під рівнем грунтових вод
і він зберігається там тисячі років і це
було частиною вуглецевого циклу вони
забрали цей вуглець з атмосфери і
замикали його і саме це регулювало
клімат і нашу температуру
близько 90% водно-болотних угідь
Ірландії було знищено частково через
індустріалізацію
це було то прямо навпроти було висушене
для колишньої торф'яної електростанції
це місце виділяє вуглець він виділяється
потрапляє у воду це все вуглець і торф
під тиском мешканців сільської
місцевості видобуток торфу залишається
дозволеним для приватного використання
але комерційний продаж торфу заборонено
під тиском ЄС який вимагає досягти
кліматичних цілей ірландський уряд все
що має намір переконати тих хто досі
спалює торф для опалення перейти на
більш екологічні методи одна з
величезних важливих речей це надання
дешевих кредитів нам потрібно переходити
на електрику для опалення і ми
збираємося виробляти величезну кількість
відновлюваної енергії в найближчі
десятиліття тут в Ірландії
Ноель конрой стурбований йому потрібен
торф щоб обігрівати будинок готувати їжу
і приймати гарячий душ
мені доведеться витратити 100 тисяч тут
і зараз щоб підняти Мій будинок до рівня
сучасних будинків А я не можу собі цього
дозволити
він відкидає звинувачення у тому що не
дбає про навколишнє середовище як і інші
він віддав своє болото державі щоб його
можна було відновити натомість отримав
менший шматок болота для власного
користування
Ми хочемо відігравати свою роль але
замість того щоб нас розпинали Краще б
допомогли нам це зробити якщо ми
відмовляємося від торфу то повинні мати
надійну альтернативу
поки що задовільного рішення немає а
припинення традиційної практики
видобутку торфу Важко уявити без значних
інвестицій
[музика]
цієї Маркс відомий шеф-кухар у Франції
Володар кількох міжленівських зірок тірі
Маркс належать до престижних кіл Парижа
але його особиста філософія зовсім
протилежна
шеф-кухар пройшов шлях від скромного
початківця до мільйонера і все це без
диплома про середню освіту він вважає що
багатство - це добре якщо ним ділитися
змирає з Афганістану користується його
щедрістю тій рій заснував у Франції
школи які дають мігрантам людям які
кинули школу та колишнім ув'язненим шанс
на новий Старт
шеф-кухар цієї Маркс Володар зірок
мішлен робить останній штрихи на равіолі
які Він подає у своєму новому паризькому
ресторані Він має гостре око на деталі
його філософія в тому що кулінарія - це
не лише про талант Він каже що всі люди
можуть це робити якщо докладуть зусиль
ства
може досягти дуже високого рівня якщо
вирішуючи налаштовані і не боїтеся
певних слів таких як дисципліна
ретельність і відповідальність ви можете
досягти вершини
усі ці риси притаманні з мораю після
втечі з Афганістану 4 роки тому йому
довелося шукати новий шлях спочатку в
Австрії потім у Франції
змарай каже що кулінарія це не просто
заробіток на життя це покликання
[музика]
У мене уже був досвід бо я вчився
готувати з матір'ю
тут у Франції Я живу з п'ятьма іншими
афганцями і готують для них Афганські
страви
[музика]
сірі Маркс із захопленням навчає таких
Ентузіастів кулінарів як змарай
[музика]
він викладає у засновані ним кулінарній
школі Кузін мод млойд Ось вам порада
коли ви готуєте заварне тісто
обов'язково спочатку добре збивайте яйця
кожен рух має бути точним А це буває
нелегко
шеф-кухар звертає увагу на кожну деталь
Я б сказав що тут все ще не вистачає
яєць
емігрантів у своїх школах
критики кажуть що він надає притулок
кожному Хто хоче готувати
У них є документи Нехай навіть із
обмеженим терміном
Ми хочемо знання що вони мали більше
свободи більше автономії і могли прожити
своє життя на французькій землі
найкращих умовах з професією
понад 6 тисяч людей пройшли навчання у
школі
не лише мігранти люди які відбули
покарання у в'язниці або не закінчили
школу
цій Марк сам не закінчив школу і його
план допомогти людям залишити свої
проблеми позаду нас не цікавить минуле
людей ми запитуємо що вони хочуть робити
зараз якщо вони хочуть готувати ми
можемо їм допомогти
для змарая це шанс усього життя
і він не хоче його втрачати
через це в мене був невеликий стрес тому
що Шеф він був тут але я щасливий що
можу вчитися у шефа цієї Маркса
ті хто пройшов тримісячне навчання і
склав іспити зазвичай знаходять роботу в
елітних паризьких ресторанах
Ми помітили що все повертає людей
вертикальне положення
вони можуть зазирнути за горизонт і
уявити як стануть відомими шеф-кухарями
і створить свій власний стиль
змарай хоче поєднати афганську та
французьку кухні одна з ідей подавати
традиційні Афганські манти або пельмені
з овочевим бульйоном у французькому
стилі
навчання я хочу попрацювати а потім
відкрити свій ресторан у Парижі
із благословення цієї Маркса який
сподівається що його учні досягнуть
такого ж успіху як він
люди які злітають у повітря і
відскакують від стіни церкви це на святе
чудо а не ортодоксальне місце поклоніння
у північному англійському місті бредфорд
боротьба поєдналася з релігією хоча
комусь це може здатися дивним поєднанням
для прихожан цей дует був укладений на
небесах
спандекс проповіді то б міг подумати А
на сьогодні це все дякуємо за перегляди
до зустрічі у наступному випуску
програми У фокусі Європа
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]